[Music]
this is the nike hyperadapt 1.0 the
hyper adapt is a myth turned into
reality it Auto laces it takes that
dream that was seen in a movie years ago
and makes it a reality that people can
actually feel this shoe it becomes alive
it shapes to your foot I personally call
it Earl or a electro adaptive reactive
lacing basically we have what we call a
lace engine that's down here on the
bottom of it and it's in a plastic
housing so it's protected it is attached
to the fit system so it's attached to
fly wire that actually comes up through
both sides and goes wraps around your
foot when the user steps in there's a
heel sensor the lace engine will run and
tighten down the fit system and then
it'll sense certain tension around your
foot and it'll stop it's a really new
experience it's the future I sometimes I
can't believe I see it right here and it
does what it does it was a dream for so
long working with tinker on this it was
incredible I mean we would run into a
problem a technical problem
we're like the mechanisms too big or you
know it can't it can't hit the ground
and he would take the design and modify
it still keeping an athlete you know and
a forefront of his mind and like add
this far across because we didn't want
it touching the ground but we needed it
exposed so that we could charge the shoe
I'm excited to not only you know
continually look for cool projects but
just working with the latest technology
existed it's amazing there's two buttons
here - to loosen plus to tighten and
just adjust it simply throughout your
day I mean it takes less than a second
to adjust and think of retying your
laces every time
make an adjustment this shoe lights up
we've seen lights and shoes before
typically they're kind of gimmicks
there's really nothing nothing about
this Earl shoe that isn't purposeful so
the lights tell you when the motors
running the light to tell you when the
batteries are fully charged the
batteries gonna last you roughly about
two weeks so when your battery's full
its blue when it gets to yellow you have
a few more days when it gets to red you
should get it on the charger right away
and so this is the charger you have to
pups because you got to charge the two
shoes just magnetically sticks to the
bottom you plug it in this blue light
will flash takes about three hours to
charge it and then you're good for
another two weeks
we're at the in the beginning stages of
all kinds of products that will change
and adapt and become more useful for
performance just being able to adjust it
on the fly at the beginning of the
basketball game versus half the time
beginning of a marathon versus the end
of marathon feet swell their sweat their
your environments always changing in
sports initially you have control of it
being able to just adjust it by pressing
the button quickly but in the future
that that's gonna happen on its own
there's a lot of people that can't tie
their shoes the fact that you can just
step into these and press a button just
simplifies that a lot and just for
quality of life is enormous all the
stuff kind of really sort of fits
together into a composition that I think
is sort of not over designed it's kind
of really meant to sort of focus on the
dogs
what's unique about it and not be too
crazy I think this has completely
changes the game it like goes from where
and didn't wear shoes to when you've
started wearing shoes technology is
changing and our ability to sort of
rethink a problem also gives you
ammunition for changing the aesthetic
it's so cool idea how good is the step
in a shoe it automatically tightens I
mean like think about that like you
should try it on just try it on
[Music]